my voice is out but I'm still gonna do
is that my phone shut the [ __ ] oh what
the [ __ ] hey what's going on YouTube oh
yeah I'm gonna sing my voice is all
baritone you try [ __ ] this what's it now
interestingly enough you guys have been
asking me to vlog about a certain topic
you guys even wanted me to explain or
express my opinions about the attack on
Paris now though I do touch on like
certain social topics there are certain
topics that I don't really think that
it's it's a really smart idea to take
light up and this would be one of those
situations now this is obviously
something that shocked the world so my
heart goes out to anybody and everybody
that has been affected by this and we're
gonna leave it at that
but having said that now there is
something on social media that I have
been noticing when it came to the
tragedy that happened in Paris this
tragic event definitely has shown some
light on all the pieces of [ __ ] on the
interwebs now what do I mean by this you
asked what people were checking their
profile pictures on Facebook to show
support for France how many people out
there saw somebody complaining about it
how does that show support that doesn't
do anything if you really want to make a
difference you would actually go out of
your house and do it for those of you
who did that can I ask you something
what the [ __ ] is going on with you yes
changing the color of your profile
picture on Facebook doesn't physically
do something but you have to ask
yourself why the [ __ ] are you bothered
by it so much it is a positive gesture
right can we agree on that no matter how
stupid you personally think it is what
does it do for you as a human being to
[ __ ] on people that are trying to do
something positive you guys are so
stupid
it's not doing anything what does that
reasoning make you feel good about
yourself listen I think all of us know
the type of person that you are you're
the type of person that just love
picking out everything that's wrong with
something for no [ __ ] reason because
it makes you feel like you're mine and
when you complain and you gripe so much
about it on social media it must mean
that you have a [ __ ] answer right bet
you don't mr. genius because when we
confront you about it without fail what
do you say
I'm just saying you would you say but
you ain't that [ __ ] to say you just love
hearing yourself warned her you [ __ ]
and the type of conversations that we
have that these type of people are
always ridiculous aren't they you have
got some stupid confucius saying or
proverb that you probably ripped off the
Instagram okay you wanna help
double-quick I'm gonna go feed the
homeless but that doesn't solve anything
I mean if you give a police a fish eats
birthday
but if you teach a clean towel to fish
ki-moon telling you for a lifetime what
the [ __ ] are you talking about that
doesn't what's wrong with you hmm
understand who the [ __ ] talks in
Proverbs how old are you you [ __ ]
crusty little just cut your thought on
tumblr it doesn't make you why is that
wrong saying that I hate these negative
ask people it's wrong no it's not I
[ __ ] [ __ ] for some reason you can't
leave positivity alone especially when
it comes to positivity that doesn't
affect people in a negative way and it
doesn't take away from somebody else you
just love complaining and whining and
telling everybody what's wrong with the
world without proposing an actual
solution you [ __ ] are just like
me and the same reason why I gotta focus
expect you understand why I'm so fast I
mean I was dieting so make a [ __ ] at
the end of the day what I want to say is
put up or shut up I think all of us here
are intelligent enough to know that
painting the colors of a french flag
onto our facebook profile picture is not
gonna stop terror it's not gonna stop
these people from doing bad things and
it doesn't bring people back to life
look we [ __ ] get it but it does show
even though you think it's stupid that
people do care people have heard about
this it has affected them and it shows a
certain amount of unity as solidarity
no matter how small it is cuz you really
do have to ask yourself this if you're
gonna sit there and tell us that these
small things aren't going to do anything
and only the big things are going to be
recognized what the [ __ ] have you done